liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
bundeskanzlerin hat heute diese debatte
eröffnet und sie hat allen vergleich
gezogen
vom jahr 2005 zum jahr 2021
das sieht ja das verstehe ich dass sie
da jojoy sagen weil 2005 rot grün
regiert hat die bilanz waren fünf
millionen arbeitslose wir hatten ein
geringeres
bruttoinlandsprodukt und deshalb ist es
gut einmal daran zu erinnern dass das 16
gute jahre für deutschland waren die wir
hier erlebt haben
wenn jetzt mitten in der pandemie
2,6 millionen menschen ohne arbeit sind
und da mal 5 millionen dann heißt das es
gibt auch weniger
armut bei kindern hängt auch davon ab ob
eltern
arbeitsmöglichkeiten haben und deshalb
ist das das erste wir müssen für mehr
arbeitsplätze sorgen das zweite sie
malen hier bilder
über
umwelt- und klimapolitik vor 16 jahren
kam knapp 60 knapp zehn prozent des
stroms aus erneuerbaren energien heute
sind es 46
es ist viel bewegt worden in diesen
jahren und deshalb ist es richtig
dass wir an dieser stelle auch der
bundeskanzlerin danken sie hat dieses
land gut durch viele krisen geführt und
all ihre schwarz malerei hat wenig mit
dem zu tun was in diesen 16 jahren
leistet worden ist
und dann gibt es immer diesen netten
spruch ja warum wollt ihr jetzt was
neues machen er hat das 16 jahre zeit
was ist er bei der digitalisierung
passiert christian lindner als auch so
ein wenig an intoniert ja die welt ja
die wahrheit die wahrheit wenn sie
wahrheit rufen da bin ich immer
skeptisch
2005 hat netflix per post dvds
verschickt die welt hat sich seither ein
wenig verändert und jetzt so zu tun so
zu tun als wenn man im jahre 2021 so
reagieren müssten wir mal 2005 reagiert
hätte ist einfach unseriös wir haben in
dieser pandemie alle gemerkt dass bund
länder und kommunen auf die
herausforderungen unserer zeit nicht
richtig eingestellt sind wenn die
gesundheitsämter mit faxen arbeiten ist
das eine ist das ist dass eine kommunale
aufgabe wenn die länder nicht schnell
gesuch sind bei der bildung frau berbalk
ist es eine länder aufgabe aber immer so
zu tun als sei alles diese
bundesregierung schuld in elf ländern
regieren sie mit und wenn es da nicht
gut läuft sind sie auch dafür
verantwortlich man kann sich nicht immer
aus der verantwortung herausziehen
und deshalb es nach 16 jahren
vieles jetzt neu zu gestalten wir stehen
an einer epochenwende wir spüren dass
alle europa ist unter druck gekommen
europa hat in der pandemie gemerkt wie
abhängig man von einer fremden macht war
selbst bei simpelsten medizinischen
gütern und insofern
wird unsere
europäische welt jetzt auf einem werte
basierten gesellschafts und
wirtschaftsmodell diese gestaltung der
zukunft auf sich nehmen müssen das geht
nur europäisch und deshalb brauchen wir
einen zusammenschluss europas und für
unser menschenbild einzutreten gegenüber
china einem herausforderer gleichzeitig
system rivale und partner gegenüber
anderen in der welt und das ist eine der
großen aufgaben die wir jetzt anpacken
müssen das gleiche gilt für den
klimawandel wir können hier kleinteilige
maßnahmen diskutieren wir werden auch
als deutschland unseren teil leisten
müssen aber wir werden diese große
aufgabe nur bewältigen als globale
aufgabe als klima außenpolitik und da
werden wir auch mit ländern reden müssen
die unser menschenbild nicht teilen mit
russland mit china mit der arabischen
welt nur wenn wir hier zu mehr
gemeinsamkeiten kommen werden wir diese
menschheitsaufgabe lösen und deshalb
rate ich uns etwas weg von diesem klein
klein hinzu dieser großen aufgabe die
jetzt in den nächsten zehn jahren vor
uns
und wir müssen will dazu nachher noch
kommen zu der frage der äußeren
sicherheit und zu der frage der inneren
sicherheit wir müssen im land mit all
unseren prozessen schneller werden wir
es hat hier
ja
finanzminister
eben beschrieben ja wir müssten mehr
wohnungen bauen ja es stimmt wir müssten
mehr wohnungen bauen sie haben die zeit
aus von helmut kohl gewürdigt wo mehr
wohnungen gebaut worden sind aber sehr
verehrter herr scholz glauben sie denn
alle ernst ist man kriegt mit mehr
vorschriften mehr blockaden mehr regeln
rot-rot-grüner berliner
wohnungsbaupolitik wo zum ersten mal
seit 2009 weniger wohnungen gebaut
wollen sind mit dieser methode würden
sie mehr wohnungen in deutschland bauen
es war eine absolute baustelle
die bauvorschriften wir haben als waren
ganz andere jedes jahr werden neue dinge
drauf gelegt in ihren wahlprogrammen
eine menge neuer vorschriften die jetzt
alle kommen sollen sie müssen aber
jemandem der geld investiert ermutigen
dass er das in wohnungen steckt dass es
attraktiv ist zu bauen und
bei aller liebe für alle liebe sehr
verehrter herr scholz man kann nicht mit
der raute durch die gegend laufen und
reden wie saskia esken das passt einfach
nicht zusammen
das gleiche
das gleiche gilt auch für die
wirtschaftspolitik wir haben in der
pandemie mit vielen milliarden und sie
haben das erwähnt
die kurzarbeit bezahlt wir haben
unternehmen hilfe gegeben dass sie gut
durch die krise kommen
das war übrigens möglich weil wir da vor
eine politik gemacht haben die der herr
präsident noch als finanzminister
verantwortet hat die schuldenbremse die
schwarze null
weil man in guten zeiten rücklagen
gebildet hat konnten wir anders als
viele andere europäische länder in der
krise helfen
ihre partei ihr parteivorsitzender
herr walter borjans ich kenne ihn aus
nordrhein westfalen hat gesagt diese
schuldenbremse das ist der fetisch von
wolfgang schäuble
der ist falsch schulden sind gut so
sollen setzen wie schulden von heute ist
steuerkraft von morgen das war doch die
politik die haben wir gegen sie
durchgesetzt dass wir solide ausweitet
haben und ich fürchte wenn nicht mehr
die union da ist wenn sie nicht mehr an
den kanzler vor sich haben der auf sie
achtet dann werden sie wieder schulden
machen und dann wählen sie wieder
steuern erhöhen wie wir das von ihnen
kennen
deshalb
gehört in den dank an die
bundeskanzlerin natürlich auch gedanken
dass sie in diesen 16 jahren zwölf jahre
gut auf die sozialdemokraten aufgepasst
hat das war eine große leistung
und deshalb muss doch die philosophie
nach der krise sein wir kommen zur
wirtschaftliche wachstum nur wenn wir
fesseln wegnehmen wenn die bürokratie
wegnehmen wenn wir freiräume schaffen
damit investiert werden kann und alle
die die jetzt darauf warten wieder zu
investieren dass wir denen nicht das
geld entziehen dass sie für
investitionen brauchen und wir haben
doch vor der pandemie werden doch vor
der pandemie alle diese lehre gemacht
mich wundert dass man das so schnell
vergessen kann
jahrelang ohne neue steuererhöhungen
jedes jahr im frühjahr die
steuerschätzung und am ende des jahres
immer mehr steuereinnahmen weil die
wirtschaft brummte weil die menschen
beschäftigung hatten weil die arbeitslos
niedrig wahrheit war und viele menschen
eingeschaltet wieso kann man das so
schnell vergessen warum macht man jetzt
wieder die gleichen fehler wie man davor
gemacht hat steuererhöhungen und
schulden machen er ist der falsche weg
und eine bemerkung zu ihnen frau berbalk
sie haben über verlässlichkeit in der
politik gesprochen wir haben dem spd
kanzlerkandidaten vorgeworfen dass er in
der lausitz nach 2038 kohleausstieg und
anderswo andere daten das ist vielleicht
sogar ein berechtigter punkt aber eines
ist unredlich eines ist unredlich und da
haben die grünen am allerwenigsten grund
hier moralisch so überheblich
aufzutreten diese große koalition
diese große koalition
hat als erster eine kohle ausstiegs
kommission berufen und den kohle
ausstieg eingeleitet das ist das erste
was man hier einmal feststellen muss und
diese kommission sollte einen
gesellschaftlichen konsens erzielen aus
gewerkschaften aus arbeitgebern aus
professor schellnhuber vom potsdam
institut aus wissenschaftlern und aus
allen umweltverbänden die daran
beteiligt waren und die sollten prüfen
verfügbarkeit und bezahlbarkeit von
strom und die sind zum enddatum
2038 gekommen sie sind zum enddatum sei
sie sind zum enddatum 238 gekommen
lassen sie sich mal von michael
vassiliadis oder anderen die letzte
nacht schildern eine einzige gegenstimme
gab es gegen dieses datum das war eine
bürgermeisterin aus dem osten wo simona
umsiedlung geht alle anderen 27 haben ja
gesagt sie haben dann ein minderheits
votum abgegeben wo sie gesagt haben wir
könnten uns auch 2030 vorstellen aber
bei einem gesellschaftlichen konsens der
wichtig ist in einer solchen frage der
wichtig ist in einer solchen frage haben
sie sich für
2038 entschieden und jetzt wird man
sehen wie sich der co2 preis entwickelt
wie leicht geht es schneller wir in
nordrhein westfalen im vest denn
schneller sein aber in ostdeutschland
hat man bereits 1990 brutalste brüche
erleben müssen und dass die menschen mal
das recht darauf haben dass wenn politik
etwas zu sagen dass das mindestens mal
ein jahr haltbar ist und nicht direkt in
frage gestellt wird wenn es gerade hier
umsetzen weg das ist der punkt um den es
geht
ministerpräsident standen sie einen
schließen
[Applaus]
vielen dank herr laschet da sie mich ja
direkt angesprochen haben und da das ja
eine der großen zukunftsfragen für die
nächste bundesregierung sein wird möchte
ich sie als erstes daran erinnern was in
diesem kompromiss drin stand sie haben
ja schon mal was behauptet was nicht der
realität entsprachen dass die
umweltverbände
dass die umweltverbände 1 2 1
2038 schuld sind und deswegen möchte ich
an dieser stelle einmal sagen was in dem
kohlekompromiss drinstand wir haben den
hier nämlich in dem deutschen bundestag
beraten und auch das gesetz was sie dann
hier als große koalition eingebracht
haben und das hat bedeutet dass in dem
vorschlag der kohle kommission drin
gestanden hat es gibt revision spumante
wieder überprüfen ob das co2 budget noch
eingehalten wird oder nicht diese
revision punkte haben sie dann hier als
große koalition in dem gesetzentwurf
daraus gestrichen erste fragen wissen
die das eigentlich zweite frage warum
sagen sie dann es wurde ein zu eins
umgesetzt zweiter punkt sie haben anders
als beschlossen den vier als kraftwerk
dass es ans netz geht mit beschlossen
als große koalition das heißt das was
sie hier gesagt haben der
kohlekompromiss wäre eins zu eins hier
eingebracht stimmt einfach nicht und da
jetzt die bundesregierung selber aus dem
bundesumweltministerium
berechnet hat dass wir die klimaziele
verfehlen wäre jetzt doch der punkt zu
sagen das was die kohle kommission
beschlossen hat werden wir die ziele
verfehlen müssen wir den kohleausstieg
vorziehen weil das ein kompromiss an dem
wir uns alle halten daher meine frage an
sie halten sie sich an die zusage wenn
wir die klimaziele verfehlen
wenn wir den kohle ausstieg vor so wie
es gemeinsam beschlossen worden ist
vielen dank für die zwischenfrage frau
bvb block die ja auch kleinen
erläuterung style noch dabei hatte der
leider nicht stimmte der leider nicht
stimmte ich bedauere dass die
umweltverbände nicht zu dem stehen was
sie damit beschlossen hat
27 jahre stimmen zum endbericht mit dem
datum 238 und da können noch so viele
menschen jetzt im netz versuchen sich
davon zu relativieren ich wünsche mir
verlässlichkeit von denen die so ein
dokument unterschreiben dass der erste
teil meiner antwort der zweite tag
zweiter tag ja es stimmt
ja es stimmt ja es stimmt es gibt diese
eckpunkte natürlich wird jetzt alle paar
jahre 2023 25 unter nach überprüft ist
das denn umsetzbar haben wir denn den
strom verfügbar wenn man immer neue
ziele festlegt
beschleunigungsphase macht für den
ausbau der erneuerbaren ist ja richtig
dann muss man aber auch die trassen dazu
bauen dann brauchen wir da planungs und
beschleunigungs verfahren und meistens
ist es ihre fraktion die als erste die
bürgerinitiative gründe gegen die trasse
auf die dritte merke das auch noch mal
ein für alle mal hier klar zu stellen
sie haben eben gesagt ein solches
wetterereignis muss man da seine politik
ändern diese wetterereignisse ja datteln
erstmal eine spenderdatei
ist jetzt gerade noch mal gerichtlich
überprüft worden die ursprüngliche
baugenehmigung ist erteilt von spd und
grünen in ihrer regierungszeit in nord
an das paar zu wissen sagt und ihre
vielen dank dass sie mich noch mal
wenn sie alles aber
jetzt kommt die kernfrage die sie gerade
angesprochen
hier muss man bei einem da okay ich
werde es weiter
die die frage die sie gestellt da muss
man eigentlich wegen ein das war in
ihrer rede wegen einem solchen
wetterereignis die politik ändern
diese wetterereignisse einen uns seit
jahren die jungen leute ältere leute
engagieren sich bei freddie for future
schon länger sind auf den straßen das
thema klima hat klaus töpfer als
umweltminister 992 bereits auf die
tagesordnung gehoben in der zeit haben
sie sich nicht gegen kohle engagierte
ganze engagement der grünen in dieser
zeit fast 20 jahre ging gegen die
kernkraft das war die falsche
reihenfolge
wenn wir den klimawandel so ernst nehmen
hätten wir erst aus der kohle und dann
aus der kernenergie aussteigen müssen
das ist eine frage die man sich sein
aber was ich ihnen wirklich vorwerfen
was mich ärgert weil es unseriös ist
215 wird das pariser klima protokoll
unterschrieben
jeder weiß das klima ein wichtiges thema
ist und sie beschließen in nordrhein
westfalen gemeinsam mit den
sozialdemokraten wenige monate vor
meinem amtsantritt im jahre 2016 wir
machen braunkohletagebau bis 2045 wir
werden den hambacher forst rodeln und
wir sind es die dann ausgestiegen sind
und sich dann am nächsten tag nach der
wahlniederlage auf die barrikade bei der
anderen seite zu stellen hat mit
seriöser politik nichts zu tun überhaupt
nichts
jetzt komme ich so ein zweiter punkt der
wichtig ist wir müssen wieder zu
wirtschaftlichem wachstum zurückkommen
das geht mit entfesselung mit weniger
bürokratie mit beschleunigten verfahren
mit unterstützung für die familien
unternehmen gerade im ländlichen raum
die jetzt steuererhöhungen als gift für
investitionen empfinden würden aber wir
müssen auch den aufstieg durch bildung
unterstützen christian lindner hat über
diese frage gesprochen die beste
sozialpolitik ist kindern aus hartz 4
herauszuhelfen aufstieg möglich zu
machen unabhängig von der herkunft der
eltern deshalb ist dieser beschluss vom
gestrigen tag im vermittlungsausschuss
ein so wichtiger dass wir auch ganz das
angebot vom 6 bis zum zehnten lebensjahr
jetzt als rechtsanspruch fest schreiben
und deshalb brauchen wir deshalb
brauchen wir hier ein anderes
verständnis von sozialpolitik kinder
stärken kinder stärken ist das richtige
und nicht staatliche umverteilung und
das ist ein fundamentaler unterschied
und das heißt dass wir anerkennen müssen
wir haben in nordrhein westfalen mit der
fdp zusammen talent schulen errichtet im
schwierigsten im schwierigsten stadtteil
die besten schule bessere ausstattung
bessere bildung bessere lehrer
schlüsseln und den kindern auch aus
einwanderer-familien
aufstiegschancen durch bildung
ermöglichen deutsche sprache schon im
kindergarten fördern damit man danach
jede aufstiegschance in dieser
gesellschaft hat und übrigens dass auch
anerkennen das ist der unterschied zu
diesen rechten teil des hauses wir haben
und er wird immer noch zitiert wenn es
gut läuft in uhr sahin beispielsweise
jemanden der hierherkommt kein wort
deutsch spricht vier jahre alt ist dann
gute bildung hat als erstes kind auf das
gymnasium geht sein abitur macht seinen
bildungsweg wacht und am ende für die
ganze welt einen impfstoff entwickelt
solche aufstiegsgeschichte solche
aufwuchs geschichten brauchen wir wieder
mehr und ich sage auch dazu diese
vielfalt unserer gesellschaft muss sich
auch in unseren verwaltungen
widerspiegeln muss sich auch in einer
bundesregierung widerspiegeln es gibt
nicht nur so talentierte leute die
impfstoffe entwickeln es gibt viele
viele tausend die immer noch nicht die
chance haben ihre potenziale
einzubringen und auch dafür stehen wir
bei leistung und bildungsaufstieg unser
prinzip ist und nicht soziale
umverteilung wie sie das in ihren
programmen haben und das dritte thema
das dritte thema ist wie kommen wir denn
zur klimaneutralität und das ärgert mich
wenn man da auch immer neue daten in der
zukunft findet was man alles 2045 und
dann und dann machen will zielpunkte
brauchen wir sind wir auch nicht
auseinander
aber was das kunststück doch ist eine
industrie die da ist und zu bauen damit
die industriearbeitsplätze auch in zehn
und 20 jahren noch da sind dass wir dann
noch stahlindustrie haben dass wir dann
noch automobilindustrie haben mich
wundert dass ja dass selbst bei einer
automobilindustrie die so sich
umgestellt hat wie wir das alle
beschreiben die ganz auf dem weg der
klimaneutralität ist dass es immer noch
gruppen gibt die jetzt gegen die iaa in
münchen demonstrieren sie blockieren
wollen sie stören wollen ich will dass
wir auch in 20 jahren automobilindustrie
in deutschland das muss doch die freude
nein und ich bin froh dass es diese
ausstellung gibt und dass wir in
deutschland die besten autos bauen und
dann muss man aber auch die grenzwerte
die man festlegt so festlegen dass
jemand damit kommt sie können beim stahl
in brüssel grenzwerte beschließen dann
ist klar das stahlwerk ist dann weder
uns als gitarren duisburg noch im
saarland zu betreiben weil wenn kohle
und eisenerz verbunden wird wird immer
co2 frei seien naturgesetze können sie
auch nicht mit geschäftsordnung im
bundestag beschließen dass es nicht mehr
gilt und ich mit zwei drittel mehrheit
ein naturgesetz ist ein naturgesetz und
wenn man will wenn man will dass die
hier in zukunft noch bleiben muss man
ihnen den weg dahin ermöglichen mit
einem übergang der es möglich macht
grünen stahl zu erzeugen mit mehr
wasserstoff dazu braucht man aber zeit
wenn die morgen abwandern südindien in
china irgendwo fahren den stahl dann
10.000 kilometer über die weltmeere mit
hoher co2 belastung und unsere
klimabilanz ist ganz toll weil 6 prozent
weniger stahl produktion drin ist wir
könnten uns wir könnten uns brüsten dass
wir eine tolle klimabilanz haben aber
die industriearbeitsplätze sind weg und
deshalb wundert mich wundert mich
das auf die spd so wenig über dieses
thema spricht diese sozial diese
energiewende muss sozialverträglich
gelingen sie muss sozialverträglich
gelingen und diese industrie
arbeitsplätze brauchen wir und deshalb
brauchen wir diesen prozess hin zu einer
klimaneutralen wirtschaft bei der chemie
beim auto weil beim stahl und in vielen
anderen bereichen mehr das geht auch nur
durch forschung das geht durch
innovation das geht nicht dass sie immer
neue auflagen für die industrie machen
denn die sind auf dem wege und wollen es
leisten und ich könnte es ihnen zehn
beispiele nennen wo das schon sehr
konkret passiert was aber nicht mit
verboten
erreichbar ist und deshalb glaube ich
dass das der kern ist wie macht man das
und dazu braucht man
wirtschaftskompetenz kenntnisse wie ein
unternehmen funktioniert wie ein
strukturwandel geht strukturen de geht
nicht mit sprüchen sondern
strukturwandel geht nur mit der kenntnis
von prozessen mit innovation mit
investitionen in batterietechnik in
grünen wasserstoff klimaneutrale
wertstoffe und und und und dazu habe ich
heute von den freundlichen wettbewerbern
keine antworten gehört so wird
deutschland jedenfalls nicht im land
bleiben wenn man den engagiert die rot
grün hier vorgetragen
wir haben nur wenig gebaut
digitalisierung heute gehört das ist der
große schub der jetzt vor uns steht die
verwaltung so umzubauen dass sie
bürgerfreundlicher wird dass das
digitale genutzt wird um diese prozesse
zu erreichen und das dritte wozu wir
überhaupt nichts gehört haben ist die
frage der sicherheit in diesem rat der
sicherheit in diesem land wenn wir für
sozialen zusammenhalt einstehen wenn wir
merken dass die gesellschaft aggressiver
wird von allen seiten aggression jetzt
auch wieder in der kroner pandemie zu
spüren ist dann heißt das doch dass wir
diesen menschen zuhören müssen dass wir
das dass wir das ernst nehmen müssen was
sie vortragen und dass wir nicht darüber
so leichtfertig hinweg gehen und in der
tat man darf es nicht auch noch befeuern
die millionen menschen die sich getestet
haben lassen und die danach sich haben
impfen lassen sind keine
versuchskaninchen bitte mäßigen sie sich
in ihrer sprache der
bundesfinanzminister beim sieg über
dieses thema wir haben doch diese
querdenker überall erlebt und ich sage
ihnen auch noch etwas auch aus ihrer
partei wenn da ein querdenker auf die
bühne springt unter herumquält dann ist
es richtig mindestens letzte mal diesen
menschen nicht kennt ihn nicht leicht
mit sicherheitskräften weg bringen zu
lassen das befeuert doch die legende
dieser leute die hier sitzen und die
unser land aufhetzen in diesen fragen
deshalb zu hören ernst nehmen was andere
vortragen
und deshalb ist sicherheit ein ganz
wichtiges thema die innere sicherheit
garantiert
nein vor hendrix es darf niemand gleich
auf die bühne springen aber die frage
ist wenn sie denen dann beruhigen und
dem eine antwort geben ob das nicht die
bessere antwort ist als er mit
sicherheitskräften von der bühne zu
beseitigen 30 jahren frage
aber sicherheit ist mehr sicherheit ist
mehr gegen der kampf gegen rechts
terrorismus es ist die größte bedrohung
in diesem land ich weiß nicht ob sie das
bestreiten hatte aber der
rechtsterrorismus ist die größere gefahr
in diesem land weil sie anschläge auf
menschen verübt weil sie anschläge auf
menschen verübt
ns ufa ein staatsversagen ohne jeden
zweifel und hier brauchen wir klare
regeln aber gleichzeitig haben wir
inzwischen einen fundamentalistischen
terrorismus wir haben
kleinkriminalität die menschen
verunsichert und deshalb muss man das
anpacken und dazu braucht man eine
haltung eine klare haltung wir haben das
wir haben das in nordrhein-westfalen
erlebt anis ambri war ein bekannter fall
13 identitäten reiste quer durch das
land jeder wusste wer er ist er war
ständig beobachtet und man hat uns dann
erklärt ja aber festnehmen kann man denn
nicht der ist ja nur ein gefährdung der
hat ja noch nichts gemacht so war die
begründung und man hat auch gesagt
man kann gefährder nicht abschieben denn
es gibt ja keinen straftatbestand der
jemand begangen hat und da hat sich
etwas geändert eine grundhaltung dass es
möglich ist wenn jemand gefährder ist
wenn er deutlich macht er will auch
töten und ist bereits zur gewalt dann
kann er festgenommen werden und des
landes verwiesen werden und wir sind ein
wir sind ein liberales ein weltoffenes
land aber wir haben ein prinzip null
toleranz und inzwischen sind in
nordrhein westfalen seit 2017 mit einem
paragraphen von dem sie gesagt haben das
geht garnicht 35 gefährder des landes
verwiesen worden wir wollen konsequent
sein da mit sicherheit in diesem land
gelingt und das ist eine frage
die man jetzt gerade nach afghanistan
auch international beantworten muss in
frankreich beginnt morgen der wichtige
prozess gegen die mutmaßlichen
attentäter von paris die anschläge
damals haben frankreich ins herz
getroffen und ich bin morgen beim
französischen präsidenten ist
freundlicherweise schon erwähnt worden
und an dem thema können sich jetzt
wieder sehen dass wir mehr europa
brauchen in der terrorismus und
kriminalitätsbekämpfung die attentäter
kamen durch deutschland lebten in
brüssel fuhren nach paris und haben die
anschläge begangen bl begangen und
deshalb ist es wichtig dass wir hier
europäisch zusammenarbeiten müssen dass
wir frankreich das besonders von
terroranschlägen betroffen war
signalisieren wir gehen diesen weg
zusammen wir werden gemeinsam in europa
für mehr sicherheit sorgen das ist das
versprechen damit terrorismus nicht
wieder so wütend kann wie im jahre 2015
und das zweite
außenpolitisch hat
dieser bundestag einmal beschlossen den
afghanistan-einsatz
2001 nach dem elften september der sich
in wenigen tagen jährt
nicht mit dem argument die taliban zu
beseitigen sondern diesen rechtsfreien
raum der da entstanden ist der ursache
war für weltweiten terrorismus für osama
bin laden für al-kaida- die aus
afghanistan geplant haben den anschlag
in new york dies zu verhindern
das war das ziel ist das ist gelungen
dieser teil ist gelungen wir haben mehr
hoffnungen gehabt am ende was sich in
afghanistan verändert das ist leider
nicht gelungen aber die lehre muss sein
dass wir jetzt alles tun die
internationale gemeinschaft und europa
das nicht erneut unter die taliban
wieder ein neuer rechtsfreien raum
entsteht der uns hier in unserer
sicherheit bedroht das ist der eine teil
und wir müssen einfach nach diesem für
den für das westliche bündnis
wahrscheinlich größten desaster seiner
gründung erkennen wo müssen wir besser
werden
sind wir europäer wirklich auf alle
ewigkeit nicht in der lage alleine einen
flughafen zu sichern und wenn wir uns
das ziel setzen ja wir müssen auch mal
handeln können wenn die amerikaner nicht
handeln das war einmal der beginn der
europäischen sicherheits und
verteidigungspolitik
1999 nach den kriegen auf dem balkan
dass wir gesehen haben krieg in europa
völkermord massen vergewaltigungen und
gestoppt hat erst die nato diesen
einsatz weil europa dazu nicht alleine
in der lage waren dann hat man begonnen
eine sicherheits und
verteidigungspolitik zu entwickeln die
in fragmenten weitergekommen ist aber 20
jahre später noch nicht so stark ist
dass wir heute auch alleine handeln
könnte und dies muss das ziel sein hier
zu mehr europa zu mehr
handlungsfähigkeit zu kommen das
bedeutet aber auch dass man sich dann
verabredet gemeinsame projekte macht
auch gemeinsame projekte macht zum
schutz unserer soldaten und das dann
aber auch in deutschland das
durchgehalten wird dass wir dann auch
sagen ja wir sind bereit zwei prozent
unserer ausgaben für sicherheit
auszugeben und das werfe ich spd und
grünen vor bei dem ersten teil der
europäischen bekenntnissen sie dabei
aber wenn es dann um die umsetzung geht
wenn es um das gemeinsame
rüstungsprojekt geht wenn es um die
bewaffnete drohnen geht dann liegt die
vorlage seit monaten beim finanzminister
weil er sich nicht gegen seine eigene
partei durchsetzt und das ist das
problem was wir haben
und deshalb muss man der haltung haben
man muss sich ziele setzen und dann
dafür auch die mehrheiten haben und will
zum schluss kommen wir haben eben ein
paar skier gehört das hörte sich an wie
eine bewerbungsrede die herr barth hier
vorgetragen hat liebe gehabt dass auch
sie erfolgreich sind da tun wir jetzt
alles dass das nicht passiert damit es
kein rot-rot-grünes bündnis gibt aber
sie haben das hier so charmant
vorgetragen um in ihrer sprache zu
sprechen müssten die leute jetzt draußen
sagen völker hört die signale
also wir wissen was da geplant ist wir
wissen was hier an begegnungen schon
auch in diesem haus schon vor den
sommerferien statt gefunden hat und
deshalb haben die bürgerinnen und bürger
ein recht darauf ein recht darauf sie
haben ihr bekenntnis und ihren mini
gesang abgegeben aber sie haben ein
recht darauf dass der bundeskanzler
werden will hier klipp und klar sagt ob
er mit einer partei die die nato
auflösen will den verfassungsschutz
auflösen will die bundeswehr abrüsten
will statt sie zu stärken die kommando
spezialkräfte auflösen will die bei
jedem europäischen einigungsvertrag
maastricht amsterdam nizza lissabon
immer nein gesagt hat ob sie wirklich
wollen herr scholz diese leute in
potenzielle bundesregierung hinein zu
rufen es ist nicht so schwer nein zu
sagen ich sage ihnen wir werden mit
ihnen nicht koalieren
ich sage
ich sage der afd mit ihnen kooperieren
wir nicht verhandeln wir nicht und
werden wir nie koalieren wir tun alles
dass sie nicht mehr in deutschland
parlamenten vertreten sind das ist unser
kampf gegen ihre haltung und diese
diese klarheit
diese klarheit diese klarheit von
demokraten gegen bestimmte positionen
die übrigens helmut schmidt auf den sie
sich neuerdings genauso gerne berufen
wie auf angela merkel der schröder höre
ich nicht so laut bei ihren berufungen
aber helmut schmidt und angela merkel
sind jetzt benchmarks helmut schmidt
hätte in dieser frage und hat immer in
dieser frage klar gestanden gegen links-
und rechtsextreme und deshalb wünsche
ich mir dass diese klarheit kommt das
ist die frage um die es bei der
bundestagswahl geht da werden wir alles
tun dass es nicht zu einem rot rot
grünen bündnis in deutschland kommen das
bewegen